As far as the scroll bar is concerned, scroll bars are one graphical way of
supplying numbers to other parts of an application. Were going to use
a traditional scroll bar in which there's it's going to be a vertical
scroll bar and it's going to have a movable part of it. That is the user
can move a part called the handle which sits in a tray. So you can move up and
down, and we when we use the terms handle and tray to indicate that we can set,
the user can set the position in the file by by moving this handle up and
down on the tray. The handle position denotes that part of the file that
should be displayed in the view port. So when you move it all the way up,
you get the start of the file, and when you move it all the way down,
you get the end of the file. Also, the size of the handle in proportion to
the size of the tray denotes the portion of the file that is visible. So
if all of the file contents fit into the viewport, you'd expect the tray to be,
filled up. And if we have a gigantic file, that in a very small window,
we'd expect just a thin handle to appear in the scroll bar.